[Musique]
Et maintenant, retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de Papi Grenier.
Papi grenier,
Papi. Papi,
coucou papi.
Oh, les enfants. Oh, j'étais dans un
monde merveilleux.
Papi, tu nous racontes une histoire ?
Oui, une histoire. Est-ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'étais pilote de
table basse ? Ouh là, je crois que je
suis pas encore complètement remis. Oh !
Oh [ __ ] ce que je vous raconter à la
fois où j'étais patron d'un parc
d'attraction, c'était en 2004.
Disneyland de Paris n'était pas encore
une boîte de nuit libertine à l'époque.
Mon seul objectif dans la vie, c'était
de lire la joie dans le sourire des
enfants.
Non, c'était l'argent. Et j'avais appelé
mon parc Fistyland.
Écoutez, Festyland, c'était déjà pris.
Alors, Fistyland, ça ressemble presque.
Oui, presque. Bon, écoutez, alors on va
appeler ça le parc atérisque.
Bah écoutez, dans mon ancien parc, on a
eu 27 morts. Alors, j'ai envie de dire,
autant prendre ça la rigolade.
OK. OK. Alors, écoutez, on va appeler ça
le Kids Crazy Kingdom.
Ça marche. Va pour Fistyland. On est
parti de pas grand-chose. Au début, on
avait une route. Bon, ça plaisait aux
gens parce qu'il y avait plein de monde
qui venait voir ma route. Mais très
vite, la porte n'a plus suffi. Alors,
j'ai réfléchi. Je savais exactement ce
qui manquait dans mon parc.
Les attractions,
des magasins. Mais c'est ça qui
manquait. Ce qui était pratique avec les
magasins, c'est que je pouvais choisir
les prix et surtout, je pouvais les
modifier n'importe quand.
Un coca, s'il vous plaît.
2 €.
Merci beaucoup. Au revoir.
Euh, bonjour. Je voudrais un Coca avec
une paille, s'il vous plaît.
Ce sera 75 €.
Et pourtant, les gens étaient pas
contents. Ils avaient une route et des
hamburgers. Qu'est-ce qu'il leur fallait
de plus ?
Les attractions.
Une mascotte.
Alors, rapidement, j'ai embauché du
personnel et comme j'étais le patron, je
pouvais même leur donner le nom que je
voulais.
Ouais, ben bonjour, je m'appelle Michel.
Je suis très content de bosser avec vous
parce que on va faire
connard, tu t'appelles connard
maintenant. Regarde, je te présente tes
collègues. Ça c'est ma couille et ça
c'est mon cul.
Comment ça va connard ? Mais non, il y a
rien à faire, il a rien de marcher. Moi,
je commençais à désespérer.
Monsieur, je vous remets ma démission.
Des attractions ça per les popètes. Mais
oui,
pour prendre leur argent, il fallait que
les gens s'amusent. Ah, vous êtes
formidable. Naruto,
arrêtez de m'appeler comme ça, je
m'appelle sang Goku.
C'est comme ça qu'on a construit notre
premier manège. Je l'ai appelé le Big
Sunder Mountain Metal Fing Rats.
Ça pl au jeunes.
C'est passionnant non ?
Bah, ça manque un peu de vie.
Mais il y a pas de problème. Je peux
modifier la musique n'importe quand.
Et combien de temps ça dure ? Je sais
pas, je suis jamais resté jusqu'à la
fin.
Salut, c'est moi, je suis Fisty. Viens
t'amuser avec moi au parc Fistyand.
Venez délirer avec nos supers
attractions. Le chemin, la grande roue,
notre poubelle en forme de coquillage et
notre super zo que vous attendez du sty
en fond du fun.
C'est fini l'histoire pap
au contraire c'est maintenant que ça
devient intéressant.
Oh petit con, rallume la lumière au
niveau que dalle. Le parc était ouvert.
Ces masses de gens répugnantes qui
grouillent. Regardez-les. Leur poche
encore pleine d'argent. Mon argent, mon
précieux argent. Il fallait être plus
rentable. Pour commencer, les boutiques
de ballons. Les gens achetaient des
ballons, c'était bien, mais une fois
qu'ils avaient acheté un ballon, ben ils
en achetaient plus après. Alors, j'ai eu
une idée.
Les boutiques de nourriture aussi, on
pouvait optimiser ça. Non seulement je
pouvais choisir le prix, mais aussi la
composition des menus. Mettez le maximum
de sel dans les frites, comme ça, les
gens auront soif.
Et une frite 2700 €.
Mettez le maximum de glace dans les
boissons comme ça on va économiser le
soda.
Pap, par pitié, je vais mourir.
Et voilà.
Ah ! Du gras dans le hamburger, plus de
sucre dans la glace. Mais
enfin monsieur, les gens vont être
malades.
Mais papi, c'est horrible.
Mais non, ça va, on en veut une
infirmerie.
Je suis désolé madame, votre fils de 6
ans a du diabète et du cholestérol.
Oh non, mon fils, c'était son
anniversaire et vu le prix de ce pas
tout ce qu'il a pu acheter, c'est ce
ballon.
Ouais, c'est ça le capitalisme, [ __ ]
De l'argent, plus d'argent. Pour
commencer, j'ai dû me débarrasser de ma
couille et de mon cul.
Enfin, monsieur, c'est dangereux. qui va
réparer toutes ses attractions
et on s'en fiche. Regardez-les, les gens
sont contents quoi qu'on leur fasse.
Regardez, tous les mardis matins, je
m'amuse à saboter des attractions et
pourtant, ça fait 15 ans que je dirige
ce parc.
[Musique]
Vous avez vu comme ce chemin est super
propre ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ma nouvelle
attraction ? Je l'ai appelé le briseur
de nuque passe de 300 km/h à 2 en une
seconde. Et je distribue même des
hamburgers bien gras à l'entrée. Je suis
pas gentil. Ah, regardez comme ils ont
l'air heureux.
Monsieur, je ne pense pas que ce soit la
bonne solution.
De l'argent, de l'argent. J'aime bien de
l'argent.
Je suis sûr qu'on peut économiser encore
là le zoette tous les animaux dans la
même cage. Mais c'est dingue ça.
Pourquoi c'est moi qui doit tout faire ?
Monsieur la spa vient d'appeler. Les
caches d'animaux seraient trop petites.
Non, je suis sûr qu'ils exagèrent.
Bah écoutez, relâchez-les.
Monsieur, être le patron du parc ne vous
donne pas vraiment le droit de tuer des
gens.
Je suis riche. Je fais ce que je veux.
Bon
d'accord.
Acheter mes ballons ou crever.
Monsieur, j'ai le secrétaire général des
Nations Unies au téléphone.
Dites-leur d'aller se [ __ ]
Achetez. Votre argent est à moi.
Le moteur de l'hélico est explosé. Qui
était censé réparer ces conneries ?
C'était mon cul monsieur. Petite futée.
Comment ça ? C'est fini papi ? Comme ça
se finit toujours dans ces cas-là les
enfants.
Chérie. Oui. Allô c'est moi. Oui. Je
vais avoir un peu de retard pour le
dîner. J'ai encore une entreprise qui a
fait faillite. Une journée horrible. Je
te rend compte pas. Oh je sais pas 200
ou 300.
Après tout on s'en fiche.
Qu'est-ce qu'on mange ce soir ? Oh
j'adore ça.
Mais papi, c'est pas une histoire ça,
c'est un jeu vidéo.
Oui, c'est ça. Prends un grand cornet de
sel plutôt. Tu as de la graisse sur ton
sel. Papi, tu nous racontes une autre
histoire ?
Bien sûr, mais ça sera pour la prochaine
fois.
[Musique]